bon allez on est parti
salut tout le monde de tous temps vous
laisse arrivé tout doucement mais
bienvenue dans quatrième hall spécial
pistols les épisodes consacrés à houston
à indiana oklahoma city sont tous en
ligne sur notre sur notre chaîne unique
ce soir on parle de b3 lesquels ingram
pistoles donc et pour ceux qui suivent
ces pré draft vous connaissez le pr 4 de
départ ils avaient à l'écran un membre
des médias nba francophone un
représentant des fans un manque
d'envergure pour par les prospects et
puis moi qui remuent la tambouille côté
média correspondant aux états unis pour
nombreux médias français francophones
dont l'équipe canal basket un faux j'en
oublie sans doute
antoine blanchard elle salue en toi
salut a tous ravis d'être là merci à toi
de ta dispo dans cette course des
playoffs c'est pas mal pas mal de ta
france moment donc c'est très bien
d'avoir cru bon de venir parler pistols
avec nous les fans sont représentés par
un autre journaliste fondateur également
dû ses impôts
oui bien sûr on a un peu partout des
lits mottin donc merci a toi d'être venu
d'avoir accepté lundi bah merci les gars
pour l'habitation toujours un plaisir de
te retrouver chaque année à la même
période les pistols abonnés à cette
période depuis dix ans donc c'est
toujours un plaisir de pouvoir parler
avec des fins connaisseurs en haïti de
blaÿ donc que laurent plaisir
plaisir partagé parce que gros tu as
vraiment sur dailymotion donc c'est très
cool à vous d'être là et pour
représenter envergure il a mis son
tee-shirt
à l'âne qui est là bien sûr qu'on va du
salut alex alu tout le monde fait un
très bon on parle de kim de quelques
nine gamme serait donc très bien
salut à tous ce coucou coucou l'équipe
dans le tchat merci d'être là encore une
fois on parle donc people's vous
connaissez le principe si vous avez déjà
vu un pré draft hall sinon je le
rappelle rapidement on va faire
état des lieux donc roster salary cap
joueurs pinet style de jeu ensuite on va
parler de la philosophie graf deux des
trois caisses qu'elle devrait suffire
qu'est ce qu'elle va suite quels sont
les bruits qui nous reviennent de du
côté des pistols et puis on va arriver à
ça maintenant la partie prospects qui on
va de racheter avec ce choix numéro 5
est ce qu il faut lutter ce qu'on
descende risque il faut traiter quel
profil il faut viser quelle fille avec
l'effectif existant et puis pour pour
être complet on y passera pas des heures
et des trois possède également le choix
46 ans provenant de brooklyn pour
cette draft alors apparemment il ya des
problèmes de connexion nous direz stream
j'espère qu'on ne va pas durer j'espère
que mon immeuble tenir à tenir le bout
et que la fibre de sao paulo va vous
prendre le pouvoir suisse se laver
correctement on commence avec une
identité pickton
le roster et là je me tourne tout de
suite vers valentin qui sont les pistols
indispensable pour la spse
au delà de keng
alors effectivement tu vois tu as mis
l'accent sur le joueur évidemment
indiscutable dans le projet des pistes
once et ces quelques lignes mais
évidemment c'est le centre du projet
mais à côté de ça je pense que là cette
deuxième saison de reconstruction avec 3
wheeler nous a permis d'avoir une belle
confirmation avec sa digue bay qui est
monté en régime toute la saison et qui
prouve qu'il est capable
dans son profil voilà d'accompagner la
reconstruction il sait que ça sera
peut-être pas une pièce n'est plus
numéro 2 mais facilement une pièce
numéro 3 ou du moins pour compléter le
cinq majeur de la reconstruction c'est
quand même très solide cet hiver à des
histoires tu as connu une saison
sophomore un peu plus compliqué que les
belles surprises de la saison rookie
mais ça reste quand même malgré tout un
élément très jeune qui peut encore se
développer donc c c'est à l'intérieur
qui qui est capable vraiment pour moi
d'être beaucoup plus polyvalent il l'a
montré l'année dernière et la montre en
fin de saison aussi que si tu lui donnes
des ballons s'il s'écarte un peu du
panier il est capable d'avoir une
panoplie
assez intéressantes toutes proportions
gardées évidemment sera jamais un rail
au kitsch ou quoi que ce soit mais on
sent que ça peut être intérieur
intéressant ce qui sera titulaire en
ligne et je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est un élément aujourd'hui sur qui on
peut on peut réellement compte et
marvin babines également depuis le trade
avec la cram benneteau le gm des pistes
entre river arrêt a récemment affirmé
que voilà c'est fait il faisait partie
des petit peu comme priorité de l'été de
le prolonger en espérant que le prix ne
soit pas trop trop cher mais mais ça
reste quand même malgré tout toute cette
bande de jeunes que 3 wheeler a fait
venir ou a draftés reste pour ma part
quasiment les seuls éléments presque
indiscutable
des pistols je vois ma devant la
devanture analystes donc c'est plus ou
moins en plus ou moins le tour après il
ya plein de petits joueurs
dont l'avenir est assez incertain les
freins jackson ça peut partir en échange
direct grande devrait partir en échange
olymique aussi ça pourrait évidemment
bouger
quant à qui il y analyse c'est
évidemment le gros point d'interrogation
il est capable de très bonnes de très
bonnes choses notamment lors de la
deuxième partie de saison mais je pense
que son statut est quand même beaucoup
moins verrouillé et protégé que kate ou
que sa digue mais par exemple donc donc
voilà donc c'est vraiment l'excel centre
centrale reste cays sadique bay marvin
baghli qui va probablement prolonger et
et stewards je pense que ça reste plus
ou moins les chouchous du gm est à
surveiller également al zayat live earth
c'est l'ancien de de michigan qui a eu
quelques minutes en fin de saison et qui
a prouvé qu'avec son retour de blessure
parce qu'il y avait une très grosse
blessure lors de sa dernière année à
l'université il s'est remis comme il
faut le fait que john b line soit dans
le la direction ça aide aussi beaucoup à
son arrivée en nba son ancien coach chez
les wolves donc donc voilà tous les
jeunes sont plus ou moins près c'est
indiscutable évidemment indispensable
mais avec
évidemment un avantage pour caïds qui
est dans l'absolu ans le seul qui peut
vraiment pas bougé du tout du roster
parce que même sa digbeu l'équipe
progresse bien c'est pas impossible
qu'on quinze jours peut-être s'il ya un
gros blockbuster trade impliquant peut
être une star confirme en nba ce serait
pas impossible que le gm craque mais à
l'heure actuelle ça reste quand même la
pièce numéro 2 du projet
antoine je te voyais hocher la tête
quand on parlait de kilian est ce ça va
être quand même des questions de cela m
aussi puisque
pour entourer on en parlera plus tard
mais pour entourer un joueur comme cas
il faut d'autres jeux d'autres porteurs
de balle il faut deux joueurs capables
de poser la balle au sol toi de ce que
tu que tu entends ce que tu vois ce que
tu cesses tu vois qu'il analyse pour
l'instant continuer avec les pistols ou
tu le vois vraiment comme de plus en
plus un trade à 7
franchement après j'ai pas une boule de
cristal van pul quoi mais c'est vrai que
ça se dit assez ouvertement que les
pistons de regarder s'il ya un très
intéressant pour eux autour de killian
ils ont pas l'air particulièrement
convaincu de son site à côté de
reckoning gamme c'est qu'il est passé
sur le banc en 6e c'est un petit peu
compliqué même s'il a eu une progression
et des meilleures choses notamment ça
reste quand même des pourcentages dans
cette seule donc
pas évident où on trouve quelqu'un
connait de la ccam unit aussi ça
s'apaise encore donc séparation qui
veulent s'en débarrasser non plus mais
c'est juste s'il ya quelque chose qui
marche bien et notamment après la leur
avant centre qui est drafté et on va en
parler
forcément les pistes on regarde euros
on a la une comment tu comment tu
définis
les pistols avec cai sur le terrain
comment ils jouent comment comment
comment ils jouent qu'est-ce-qu'il
quelle est l'identité de jeu de cette
équipe c'est une équipe ii 2 mi terrain
c'est une équipe de transition
[Musique]
je trouve que pour les avoir beaucoup
regardé parce que je voudrais pas se
regarder l'évolution quelqu'une
également dans son arrivée en nba je
trouve qu'il ya eu plusieurs moments
dans leur saison au début et caïds
revient de blessure donc il n'est pas
très en confiance épuisé ses débuts en
nba dont qui lui donnent parfois la
balle parfois il devait jouer un peu
plus loin du ballon et je trouve que
devra partir de février on a eu ce qu'on
ce qu'on pensait voir c'est-à-dire key
de manieurs de ballons sur pick'n roll
sur demi terrain beaucoup dans drive in
teak avec cette belle île verte dans les
corners qui pouvaient jeudi pick'n roll
malheureusement sans réelle menace de
loeb parce que stewart est pas très
verticale donc c'est quelque chose qui
me manquait beaucoup je trouvais à eau
pistols bon choix 46 peut-être qu'on
pourra le retrouver ce genre de rumeur
mais l'équipe qui fait beaucoup de mes
terrains et qui perdaient pas mal de
ballons parce que c'est manieurs de
ballon était jeune et c'est normal mais
je pense une équipe qui risque de plutôt
être sur un tempo plus lent
et d'autriche ont vraiment en
attaque attaque rapide parce qu'ils ont
un joueur capable de prendre très
souvent les bonnes décisions ballon mois
sur pick'n roll donc eu autant utiliser
ça à foison
la lente un tutu valide on était on
était sûrs du pick and roll ou aussi pas
mal sûr de l'iso j'ai pas j'ai pas
regardé les stats
bah en fait là le projet il est
tellement
son balbutiement en fait comme l'a dit
alan ya eu un peu de tout dans cette
saison parce que l'identité paul non pas
claires pas claire pour différentes
raisons parce qu'il n'y a pas non plus
énormément de talent capables de dd qui
est cliquable donc c'est vrai que là il
a un peu tout seul au monde et c'est
surtout le talent là et l'intelligence
des caïds qui faisait
l'identité de jeu du soi on a
l'impression qu'en une semaine on
pouvait à la fois être un une équipe de
transition au parfum une équipe de 2000
terrain donc ça a changé un peu tout le
temps et comme l'a dit alan stewart
n'était pas encore assez bon en
verticalité pour pouvoir aller chercher
les ballons très haut et permettent
accueille 2 voilà d'être une menace
sur alley hoop mais l'arrivée de marvin
baby a quand même et fait beaucoup de
bien dans ce sens
marvin en plus ils étaient vraiment
motivés il était revanchard après son
entrée à sacramento il était en en année
de prolongation de contrat
c'est quand même une équipe qui voilà
qui voulaient baghli baghli voulait les
pistols depuis un petit moment dans les
papiers le trade ses enfants fait il
devait presque se faire même l'été
dernier on en parlait mais sacramento
voulait sa digue est donc très weaver a
évidemment dinan et finalement il l'a eu
en gardant en gardant sa big ben et
quelques quelques mois plus tard donc
c'est pour la com dans le projet marvin
va lui il a un rôle mine de rien qui est
encore pas assez
discuté parce qu'il vient d'arriver mais
ça peut vraiment être la belle surprise
du projet et je pense que le style de
jeu et l'identité de jeu la philosophie
mise en place par les pistonnés prado et
esi arrivera
quand il y aura vraiment des cadres
installés et c'est aujourd'hui à part
quelques unités c'est difficile de
savoir qui sera au pistoles ben non et
une fois qu'on aura trouvé voilà les le
sutdio ce trio de auquel sur lequel
reconstruire sur lequel bâtir notre
équipe et aux fables là on pourra
commencer à voir est ce que le coach est
un problème qui identité de jeu mettre
en place
mais voilà évidemment ça va dépendre de
qui on va le racheter cette année ce qui
va exploser tout de suite est-ce que ça
va être quelqu'un à développer sur le
long terme est ce que ça va être un mec
très dès septembre on en parlera mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une identité
claire mais avec l'intelligence de jeu
et le talent de kate fera accueil de
décider plus ou moins comment les
pistols joueront
antoine défensivement
de toit de ce que tu as vu ce que
ce que tu as pu observer des pistols et
kehl quel genre d'éclipsé est ce que
c'est une équipe souvent assez
agressivement ce que c'est des schémas
plus
conservateur avec du drop parce que on
va mixer avec de la zone que ce que tu
en as vu
alors je vais pas mentir j'ai énormément
gars des vues
franchement très tôt
une victoire d'être la pire équipe à
l'est le magic s'est abattue sur les
photo finish on va dire d'ailleurs ça
leur réussit pour la draft si l'on le
premier choix mais oui quand on était
encore un petit peu suivie
et qui alors ça va faire de son staff
mais tu as quand même tenté pas mal de
chose qui n'est pas resté dans une
inflexibilité qu'on lui a donné
souvent attribués donc voilà ce que
c'est compliqué de faire une défense
très agressive
si t'as pas des joueurs qui sont hyper
consacrer à sa non plus ensemble donc du
coup
voilà ces substituts comme quand une
équipe marche pas c'est compliqué de
dire encore une fois on a dit
apparemment d'identité
c'était voilà c'était une équipe qui a
ramené un petit peu mais le souvenir que
j'en ai que je n'étais pas trop croisé
en fin de saison c'était plutôt au moins
ça tente un petit peu des nichons par ci
par là ce qui est donné ici il va rester
douanes qu'ici c'était km dont le projet
le jeu va au moins s'installer avec la
stabilité d'un coaching staff
je pense que vu tout l'instabilité qui
en rappelle quand même qu'ils ont
commencé la saison avec aucun joueur de
la saison
2019 2020
si on continue et de l'instabilité dans
notre projet ça va être compliqué là je
pense que déjà c'est trop louis veur la
limite qui arrive à être un peu plus
testé question ses capacités à vraiment
aller chercher un pic n'est pas évident
pour un top 5 dans cette traque pour on
sait que c'est surtout les trois
premiers qui sont indiscutables est ce
que vraiment ils arrivent à trouver le
bon truc sachant que voilà qui gagnent
est drafté cet pape a l'air de bien
fonctionner et s'éteint donc il ya du
boulot mais je vois personnellement
j'aurais pas dû laisser partir
maintenant alors qu'il ya eu des bonnes
choses qu'on était
aussi
ce que c'est plus haut niveau de
l'exécutif par
alan pour se projeter sur les joueurs
qu'on pourrait drafté à côté de caïds du
coup
quel genre
de leader et kate cunningham est ce que
aujourd'hui on voit dans les clae yoff
évidemment ça c'est le scénario dans x
années c'est pas scénario l'année
prochaine mais une équipe de playoffs à
detroit avec key dans leader est ce que
caïd est un leader plus à la tête tout
cas peut-être un peu moins de ballons
mais qui a une équipe un peu plus
versatile autour de lui ou plus à la
donne cheechoo avec beaucoup de ballons
énormément de responsabilités dans ce
cas il faut un goût de bolland de leurs
à côté des rimes rohner et surtout des
gars carthy partout
pour moi dans le moine feps comportement
ils se rapprochent présidente at home
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui est peut-être
pas le plus expressif qui est pas d'en
parler dans le podcast en d'années qu'on
avait fait sur lui c'est pas il n'est
pas labellisé mamba mentality mais ça
veut pas dire que c'est par un leader
c'est parce qu'il ya plusieurs types
effet de faire des formes de 10 heures
si on le voyait toujours très vocal avec
ses coéquipiers peut-être plus de ce
temps là réserves sur certains sur
certains aspects après dans le style de
jeu bah oui c'est c'était le prospect le
dernier prospects capable selon tous les
spécialistes qu'on vous voyez pouvoir
mener une attaque héliocentrique donc
plus dans le délire luca mais en fait
les attaques héliocentrique s'ils ont
regardé les journaux centre et qu'ils
ont tous leurs limites un moment aux
play-offs même ceux qui sont chez moi
quasi parfait comme tu l'as dit bon le
cac est en plus
des salles et cinq meilleurs joueurs du
monde en plus malgré même ça dans son
schéma on voit un plafond de verre un
moment donc je pense que le bon mix ça
serait une menace de loeb ce qui est
marvin bagley mais une menace optent
pour protéger le cercle c'est mieux des
shooteurs dans les coins et un deuxième
volet de leur parce qu'en fait c'est lui
qui fait quasiment 2 mètres sur la
possibilité de le faire jouer avec ce
qu'on appelle un meneur pour
défensivement donc un autre porteur de
balle puisque se met dans la foi entre
guillemets s'occuper des meneurs
adverses en défense parce que qu'est
pour être décalé plus sur les poses de
3,14 cette offre une vraie polyvalence
ce qui se passe pendant un an à détroit
dallas avec luca et bronson okaïdi midi
parce que c'est trouver ce deuxième
porteur de balle c'est une priorité pour
moi j'ai vu que pour moi c'est une
tranche à 5 joueurs et qu' il ya de
porteur de balle dans cette draft c'est
sur quoi j'ai montré clairement
on va commencer à aller là dessus on va
parler de la stratégie draft valentin
est ce que qu'est ce qu'on en a dit du
côté des trois déjà de cette stratégie
de draft
j'afficherai le l'historique de treuils
wever qui est impliquée depuis longtemps
dans les dents les draft puisqu'il était
raide ce casting à utah avant d'être
assistant gm a ok si puis general
manager de détroit est ce qu'on va
chercher du potentiel est-ce qu'on va
quand même regarder la complémentarité
comme en toile de six minutes à l'heure
avec kate puisque l'on sait que ça a
déjà pas très bien marché même si
c'était l'année un relais killian
voilà que qu'est ce qu'on en a dit
bats pour ma part a déjà comme n'importe
quel bon gm la question elle est
évidemment elles évidemment bonne mais
tu te trouver un équilibre et tout ça et
il faut savoir être à prendre un pic on
va dire qu'il va être complémentaire
avec teta base mais qui a quand même du
talent et du potentiel à développer et
dans ce cas là des trois ne peut pas se
permettre aujourd'hui de draft est
quelqu'un qui
qui est déjà un petit peu qu'un cursus
universitaire complet je pense pas en
bas âge qui gagnerait murray ont dans
lequel on entend beaucoup parler en ce
moment ce à quoi qui commencent à
grimper mais la presse locale du
michigan on dit que que sa cote à
détroit commencé à grimper à muret donc
à voir mais ça me vois pas en fait trois
heures prendre un rookie de 21 22 ans
là je ne vois vraiment cher aller
chercher un un deuxième gros talent donc
je pense qu'il va prendre le le plus
gros talent disponible en 5 il le
prendra et en termes de profils bombe à
détroit s'est fait un peu avoir à la
loterie donc c'est vrai que tous les
débats de la saison ont tourné autour
des 3 devant
aujourd'hui le débat était forcément
totalement remis à zéro on parle
beaucoup plus de haili on parle beaucoup
plus de sharp évidemment on parle
également de gris film parce qu'on est
un bruit de couloir qui annonce que
l'épisode voudrait activement récupérer
le pic sept ans balourd dans jira
migrantes à portland donc c'est vrai que
si on arrive à voir le 5 et 7
ça serait déjà une stratégie nouvelle
mais à l'heure actuelle avec le pic 5
uniquement je pense que qu'on va prendre
le meilleur le meilleur joueur
disponible le plus gros talent kkr de
jeunes qui ont peu développé et qu'on
puisse s'en tout est très complémentaire
avec kgs c'est là c'est la mission
principale parce que je m'en fais pas on
en parlait tout à l'heure de l'état des
lieux un joueur comme ça dit bo pourra
le [ __ ] en deux ans trois parfois même
il a des amis en quatre
domaines clés easy donc sa digue mais va
tranquillement se fondre dans le
collectif s'en soucie peu importe qui on
prend cette année donc l'idéal c'est
trouver celui qui est le plus
complémentaire avec avec kate et comme
marvin baghli semble être vraiment dans
les papiers de notre gm je pense qu'on
va prendre forcément un world dont xetra
sharp ou arriver maintenant quel est mon
préféré pour le moment assez compliqué
j'ai pas les mêmes connaissances que
vous sur le sujet je pense qu'il ya des
risques des deux côtés mais un vieil de
naïve et je pense que ça peut vraiment
être pas mal à côté d'eux à côté de deux
caïds et surtout un poil moins risqué
parce que ça reste malgré tout un pic
quand même assez important dans la
timeline des pistols et on connaît
évidemment l'historique de sharp et j'ai
peur que ça soit un risque un petit peu
trop gros pour detroit
malgré le talent évident du bonhomme on
va y venir sur ces deux profils
évidemment qui semble se détacher mais
avant ça je pose quand même la question
à antoine on sait jamais quelles sont
les bordes des différentes équipes pour
la draft six arrivées le haut pic 5 le
poids numéro un des pistons
se portent sur un intérieur est ce qu'il
faut le prendre ou est ce que on va un
petit peu
tergiverser en se disant ça serait bien
d'avoir un autre porteur de balle comme
le disait n'a longtemps comme l'a dit je
vienne
c'est compliqué à répondre moi je suis
pas dans la war room mais on est en plus
on se projette à l'avance
en plus si si si dans ce cas de figure
cela pouvait aussi bouger derrière on a
mentionné la d'effectivement qui fait
pas mal parler de récupérer la septième
position aussi avec
moi j'ai tendance à dire que quand même
sur les ligne d'arrières il ya une
chance qu'ils fassent un petit peu une
priorité quand même il ya une forme des
joueurs et c'est la maison quand même si
on l'a dit avant de souligner n'y a pas
de deuxième porteur de balle ça pose des
vrais problèmes il me semble que des
grands on peut aller en chercher on
parle développer sur un deux trois ans à
saas-fee un porteur de balle qui
vraiment apporter la qualité c'est pas
sûr qu'ils auront encore un top 5 que ça
fait plus classe plus tard
je me dis qu'il ya une petite chance que
ça se sent qu'ils sur leurs priorités
mais bon je le dis sans infirmation une
paire en france non plus un de ses
alors une donnée importante je sais que
je fait patienter avant qu'on passe au
feat avec les deux les deux les deux
arrières qui se dit samedi s'annonce
disponibles en tout cas aux pics sont
peut-être un des deux au moins
c'est les futurs choix de draft de nos
amis des pistols qui n'ont plus beaucoup
pour la suite en tout cas qu'ils auront
les leurs sauf s'il
performe très bien et qui vont en
playoffs c'est en gros ce qui va se
passer
puisqu'ils doivent en tout cas ok si
mais voilà les futurs pic ce qui vous
regarde et un petit peu je sais pas si
on le voit si ses cachets voici c'est
bon donc ils ont que les leurs ce bon
tour donc à l'année ce que
déjà à l'année prochaine on peut tous se
mettre d'accord pour dire que detroit ça
serait très étonnant qu'il soit en
play-offs sais pas si mon talent
c'est pas grave je la fais dagorn sa
noble maintenant mais oui je pense aussi
se battre pour le plein peut-être mais
comme un livre à lanton en début
d'épisode mois et qui fait trop trop peu
profond est trop jeune et trop peu
inexpérimentée ça voudrait dire peu
s'ils veulent vraiment compétitif entre
aux gens ça voudrait dire là où il ya du
cap space à venir les chercher des
joueurs à la craie john site ce qui est
possible mais ce qu'est ce que t'es pas
trop le l'idée peut-être accéléré en
termes d' accélérateur de particules du
projet je pense qu'à le temps entre
guillemets et à récupérer ta pépites
comme les choix de draft après comme
comme l'a dit il faut réussir la drogue
d'après et puis la drogue d'après et
développer ce qu'on avait déjà donc mais
l'effectif c'est sûr que c'est pas un
effectif qui aujourd'hui
va exactement jouer les play-offs en 10
l'an dernier c'était les hornets ils ont
gagné quasiment tout 40 matchs de
mémoire on voit pas des trois gagné 40
matchs l'an prochain et c'est pas grave
si l'on gagne 34 35 sera déjà vraiment
bien
on a donc l'historique de drap de
travail weather alors c'est pas tout le
temps lui qui appuie sur le mythe on est
bien d'accord mais mais avec utah une
pelletée de non j'ai pas mais j'avais
pas la place mais une pelletée de nos
ratés au deuxième pour qu'ils sont assez
inter sur les dents spéciales cos
mai mais deron williams paul mills a
quand même drafté dans la période où il
est allé dans ce cas où tina butin sur
trois ans c'est pas mal quand même de
choper de talent comme ça c'est pas des
pick up au top 3
sont des ninjas boire deuxième tour
avec ok si on a de racheter un seul
westbrook hockey et après pas mal
d'athlètes et bassa marché moyen on va
le dire c'est plutôt des défenseurs avec
des gros outils long winston et ses
longues envergure pardon et
et ben ça plus pas marcher que marcher
quand même dans l'ensemble aux personnes
- justice
et depuis qu'il à détroit alors valentin
drafté leavers drafté paye même drafté
garza et pas des joueurs athlétiques
même cas il n'est pas labellisé comme ou
beurs athlètes quoi
même si c'est un très bon athlète en
tension
puisque il a eu la chance lozeau fille
est ce que il a fait des déclarations
chez pas aujourd'hui le chou c'est très
important non pas drafté du joueur sache
où tu es
bon en fait déjà ce qui est un peu
compliquée en tout cas c'est c'est ce
qui ressort à détroit dans la fanbase
que ce soit aux états unis ou en france
c'est que s'il ya eu des petites choses
à reprocher à troy sur le marché des
free-agents sur la draft à chaque fois
ou presque surtout sa première draft
avec kilian sadique baisse tout art
c'est quand même des drafts globalement
réussie par rapport à un ce qu'on avait
connu avant des trois franchises réputé
pour souvent se rater au draft 1 hormis
l'udc ténors des peut-être andré de
rimogne sous le reste du temps c'était
quand même assez moyen stanley johnson
greg monroe et c'est donc c'est vrai
qu'on a eu des on a eu aussi est loyal
henson donc voilà on a vu des graves
quand même assez moyenne avant l'arrivée
de de wever et l as quand même pas mal
de travail qui fait le problème avec
trois heures s'est en fait sa
communication toujours assez
mystérieuse il aime bien un peu joué aux
minimes comme l'année dernière quand il
nous fait croire que peut-être diawling
ring était son numéro un ou peut-être
william ceci patrick williams donc c'est
vrai qu'elle aime bien il aime bien
jouer à ça donc ça qu'on a toujours un
peu de mal jusqu'au dernier moment à
savoir qu'elle est vraiment ce qu'ils
recherchent là il a fait une sortie
médiatique une seule seulement depuis la
fin de saison c'est après la loterie et
il a dit qu'il avait entre cinq et neuf
joueurs qu'il apprécie énormément dans
cette draft donc il n'a pas les deux
premiers tours et là je dis qu'elle
avait 9 qui l'apprécié énormément et il
n'a pas non plus de réellement de
profils techniques
treiber il aime bien des profils déjà
avant tout très
branché sur il faut un mec qui bosse
faut pas un mec arrogant faut pas un mec
qui vous le saguenay bref il faut pas un
mec comme jeanine green dans la presse
par exemple il aime bien les mecs posé
qui bossent qui se font dans un
collectif
treiber il est vraiment dans le sens on
va faire un truc familial un peu c'est
un peu l'idée qui est qui fait il n'aime
pas les mecs qui le cliché du basketteur
arrogant et qui va être trash talk tout
le temps c'est vrai qu'il ya pas qu il
ait pas trop comme ça beaucoup de good
guys drafté depuis qu'il est arrivé un
sadique baisse à bien un programme sur
avec tila nova isaiah stewart était
reconnu pendant le processus très grave
pour être le joueur vraiment le plus
impacté yo nan pendant les interviews
etc je sais que j'ai oublié d'ailleurs
stewart sur ma liste
même l'hiver voilà les gaza sont connus
pour être des joueurs très travailleur
effectivement mais aussi dans le dans la
joie et la sagesse
antoine une question pour toi qui suit
cliquez dans la sphère média une bille
est ok ce qu'on en dit de troy wever
est ce que c'est un personnage est ce
que c'est quelqu'un comme disait un
homme très secret ou est ce qu'on en
sait quand même deux trois trucs
là je t'avoue que j'ai pas énormément de
débit sur le sujet je préfère le dire
clairement
un an qu'on connaît c'est certain qu'on
attendait aussi un petit peu puisque ça
sort un petit peu de effectivement des
problèmes en tout cas si donc on
s'attend à ce que ce qui se passe de
bonnes choses mais encore une fois comme
tu le disais avant là il est quand même
un petit peu en questionnement
d'un petit peu est ce que il peut il
peut vraiment conscient à quelque chose
à detroit donc c'est plutôt le moi ce
que j'ai retenue dernièrement c'est
surtout que là c'est un petit peu un
test pour lui ce qui va se passer sur
cet art ça c'est important quand même à
retenir ça veut dire que pression
peut-être moins de prise de risque et on
va voir comment ça se passe avec
nos deux zigotos le la finale femmes
c'est parti c'est parfois quand et de
hauts murs que tu prends de plus tôt
risque donc d'y psd roissy
baroin s'était pas sinon voilà
surtout cas ok si sa draft des joueurs
qui sortent du chapeau 1 aux personnes
mais stis c'est pas des des joueurs qui
sont attendus à ce niveau là mais c'est
plus bas dans la graph qui à moins de
n'y a pas la pression du jeu draft top 5
alan voilà il aurait pu il avait pas de
pression s'il se retrouve avec le top 3
hélas ce truc du top 5 ça met un peu la
pression
est ce que une nouvelle fois je te
reposes la question je pensais déjà
posée est ce que c'est une draft et
trois joueurs comme comme il semble être
la légende qui s'écrit sur les colonnes
du spn
non pas une draft à 3 heures c'est une
grâce à deux joueurs ou une grotte à
cinq joueurs ça dépend mais c'est normal
que les gens pensent que c'est une draft
à trois joueurs parce que la draft c'est
quoi c'est un consensus qu'on en a qu'on
dit aux gens d'aimer moi et moi et moi
pour la tarte et par des mots gradés big
board des journalistes américains et des
convois un petit peu dans hors de ce
consensus bas nous dit qu'on dit
n'importe quoi donc par contre se
regardent souvent dix ans après bah
finalement c'est quasiment jamais ce que
les gens elle va annoncer au moment qui
se passe donc pour moi c'est une droite
à cinq joueurs
deux joueurs donc j'ai deux jours dans
mon tir 2 et 3 jours dans mon tir deux
jours dans mon terrain et trois jours
dans mon tir 2 donc c'est une draft as
un joueur parce que j'ai personnes dans
ce tir 1 tout seul en haut qui est
vraiment incroyable l'année dernière
comme calé dernière comme luca comme
bayonne c'est ces jours là est la
différence entre les deux premiers les
trois suivantes et pas incroyable y en a
une clairement qu importe l'équipe que
je serai je prendrai ces deux jours là
haut donc cetto mme venne et paolo
gontero mais pour moi c'est une grosse
phase un joueur ce qui positionne
détroit dans une très bonne place
si
les franchises pense comme toi il est
possible que j'ai donné vie celle de
sharp soit déjà parti dans le top 4 et
que des trois se retrouvent à pouvoir
choisir
que sais je
global zero jabbari smit j'ai déjà lu il
ya des relations et des rumeurs qui
sortent tous les jours on va pas tout
les commenter mais
des rumeurs de gedo nagui top 3 on a vu
chez les jeunes charpente - j'avoue mais
mais des rumeurs de gedo nagui qui monte
oui et des rumeurs qui gagnent leur est
top 5 des rumeurs john et délices top 5
il a demeuré top 5 voir ailleurs on n'a
été normal c'est
aussi vendre un peu de papier avant la
draft est tout à fait normal certains
hésitent ryder et jean dans les mois et
dans les places faire en sorte bien il
parle avec des gènes parle avec des gens
et on leur dit adam c'est nous on aime
bien sûr là donc ça fait une info
peut-être que sans citer bien sûr et
puis et puis c'est le jeu donc je
rappelle juste aux gens qui nous
critiquent l année dernière nous vous
expliquerons côté barnes tout le temps à
votre insu on nous disait qu'on disait
n'importe quoi or là c'est le consensus
et patatras pas toujours raison donc est
d'ailleurs beaucoup j'ai été surpris que
toronto prennent
prennent barnes ce soir dadraf ce qui
prouvait que deux heures et son propre
bord de sa propre évaluation par rapport
à tout ce qui mettait quasiment tout le
temps seul devant donc moi je m'attends
à potentiellement déçu mais je pense
quand même que le top 3 vendues par tout
le monde il risque deux sortes peut-être
les trois premiers mais je suis pas sûr
que je pas persuadé une question et toi
non plus sachant qu'un raptor justement
a bien travaillé alors consensus
qu'elles soient délogés du skating
une manière de travailler
car il ya des gens qui sont extraits de
pas travailler au sein de l'organisation
parce qu'ils veulent même pas avoir un
consensus entre donc novateur que
l'ancien comptable 14 mois lev vous dire
aux états unis l'exception pour
justement pas sans différence c est que
quand ils arrivent c'est vraiment un
très très gros truc comme ça il faut
absolument tout le monde et des habits à
cet hiver avant et tranchées et et que
lui il ya un maximum d'informations
comme ça à intégrer à tout le monde un
peu est d'accord il lui fait un tour des
béni oui oui quoi donc du coup c'est pas
c'est pas étonnant du coup sûr un profit
comme les comme les raptors
valentin est ce que tu as tu as des
infos sur comment on travaille justement
du côté de détroit on avait eu
et elliott qui a un français qui dans le
staff
l'année dernière voilà est-ce que est ce
que c'est une philosophie assez
classique de travail ou est ce qu'il ya
des
jeux c'est pas des particularités c'est
une saurait imaginer
déjà l'avantagé c'est que c'est un front
office qui est très très
avec beaucoup beaucoup de statuts
différents
comme je pense dans beaucoup de
front-office que c'est vrai qu'il ya
trop bieber aime bien s'entourer de
beaucoup de monde et lui même en tant
qu'ancien en tant qu'ancien anga
spécialisée dans le scouting et où c'est
quand même un gm de base qui a été
recruté avant tout pour le processus de
draft aux pistols avant même avant même
la free agency s'est d'ailleurs les gros
pour l'interrogation qu'on avait quand
elle arrive à détroit parce que son
premier gros poste de gm c'est ce qui va
être capable de gérer la free agency
plutôt cité salle de la question parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui est très réputé
quand même dans déjà depuis des années
dans le secteur de la du scouting dans
le secteur voilà de la volaille et c'est
donc c'est un gm qui aime bien quand
même avoir les mains surtout les toutes
les recherches tous les dossiers tout
processus draft par contre ils sont
hissés s'encadrer de plusieurs
assistants
spécialisés évidemment dans chaque
division bon ça c'est assez classique il
a évidemment ses sources aussi en europe
et compagnie mais mais par contre c'est
quelqu'un qui met beaucoup l'accent sur
le la rencontre etc il est pas toujours
dans l'analyse
vraiment tactique etc des vidéos un
petit peu c'est un mec qui si il va
faire sa base on va dire que des
recherches
évidemment en regardant les matchs mais
en lisant avec avec ses collègues et ses
assistants et c'est par contre très
rapidement il va essayer de rentrer en
contact que ce soit avec la fac que ce
soit avec le joueur en question d' assez
tôt pour le rencontrer parce que encore
une fois c'est quelqu'un qui met
beaucoup l'accent sur le côté humain et
il le vite savoir si ce mec là peut
rentrer dans l'état d'esprit la
philosophie du projet dans dans on va
dire le le la shark un peu morale que
qui veut mettre dans le beau dans le
vestiaire des pistols donc c'est
quelqu'un qui y va aussi mettre l'accent
ce pour rencontrer beaucoup les les
coaches des jeunes au lycée il aime bien
retourner à la base des choses il va en
jeu c'est quand même manière il avait
énormément rencontré quelques années une
gamme le frère de kate il avait
rencontré évidemment la famille il avait
rencontré
les gens qui le côtoyaient au lycée
parfois il aime bien rencontrer même des
potes d'enfance c'est quelqu'un qui va
retourner pour vouloir cerner un peu le
profil du gua donc c'est quelqu'un qui
aime bien quand même s'éloigner du côté
basket et lui il est surtout chargé de
ça trois hivers puisqu'il fait
évidemment confiance à tous et
assistance ou côté vraiment technique
défensif offensif et c'est donc c'est un
mec qui lui met beaucoup l'accent son
côté humain et c'est pour ça que tout un
petit peu les dernières ça vous de me
dire si je me trompe mais sharp par
exemple histoire qui a eu par rapport au
lycée le fait qu'il n'ait pas joué ici
déblais il a le fait qu'il est il a
quitté la compagne pendant la presse ça
c'est des petits trucs qui me font
peut-être dire que sharks ne sera pas là
la priorité de 3000 heures et qu'il aime
bien mettre par exemple je sais aussi
que c'est un mec qui aime bien prendre
des risques comme disait il disait
antoine pons pour moi je pense que c'est
plutôt le genre de gm quito mur peut
faire une grosse dinguerie par exemple
c'est plus ce genre de gm et je vois que
will en parler dans le vide dans le chat
si la combined
démontre prouve que griffin de duke son
carnet de santé et un petit peu moins
grave qu'on le pense griffin c'est un
mec le je pense koch énormément de cases
pour river que ce soit en 5 ou en fait
si on récupère le pic de port klang je
sais que beaucoup de fans des pistols
rêverait d'un d'un ivy avec griffin
ancêtres et si on arrive à faire le
diola eyvigues griffin je sais c'est le
genre de chose que il aimerait il
aimerait faire trop buveur parce qu'il
veut frapper je pense qu'il veut frapper
un gros coup cet été parce qu'on a en
plus 40 millions à dépenser sur la free
agency on est l'équipe qui a le plus de
fric donc je pense que c'est un été en
effet comme l'a dit antoine pas décisif
dans le sens où s'il le rate il va être
viré mais par contre tu as peut être le
projet des pistes on peut prendre un
virage assez énorme je pense que l'on
était de 2,3
sur griffin je veux juste jeter que dont
les quinze que pitt qui coche c'est le
fils de l'assistant et guyane miss linky
et aux raptors on s'est vraiment une
famille très basse et sa soeur aussi qui
va arriver à la draft est de beaulieu
nba n'est d'après il me semble
on va voir les bras tendus autant que
son frein mais bon il lui reste un an
pour faire ses preuves
c'est voilà il compte utiliser ça fait
10 passes et perdu aucun bien sûr donc
il ya tous côtés en poney de l'état
d'esprit du zouk etc donc c'est vrai que
c'est ça ça fit très très très de
retraite fabien dessine on encore un peu
plus derrière j'aimerais qu'on va
trouver là il ya quand même
au niveau or constitue pas plus que des
bons temps sur les mentalités et au
niveau physique il a quand même une
vraie passante pour les produits longs
et athlétique ça c'est quand même on va
dire une petite spécialité weaver
mais en même temps on la ligue
bien sûr
en fait il est si je dois résumé ce que
tu disais c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
reste et ce chaos dans sa tête ça c'est
le travail des scabs terrain d'aller
d'aller rencontrer les familles de se
rencontrer
de savoir si l'entourage est sympa au
pas les braises cloud c'est pas la vidéo
room c'est deux choses un peu
différentes alan john hayes vie aussi un
pedigree de basketteur
très important de deux bars à merde
où sa mère était dans ce top des
magnifiques roses lys et de la coach de
l'équipe de basket de nos torts des
baskets mode féminin dû prendre de notr
diamond siècle il ya une famille de
sportifs avec des grands et des plus
froids des membres masculins de familles
qui ont été joueur professionnel de
football américain
donc oui là le tout le cursus honorum
midi du fils de
famille de sportifs avec la mentalité
qui va avec lyon l'a vu compétiteurs
ultra gagnant dans plusieurs contacts
avec timmy aux effets avec purdue donc
oui pour
celles à la politique de weaver et koch
a pas mal de 15
j'adore quand tu dis course us ou non
nador dans l'immobilisme il faut tout le
temps qu'il a aimée années d'histoire
doivent être mises à profit
à l'essai et c'est à ton tour d'être
d'être concis et précis à la donne moi
des différences entre jena lee hayden
chars
sharkfoot mieux en sortie de dribble
shannon sharpe avec plus verticale des
de naïve et plus
tranchant au loin du ballon du canal vie
est un meilleur passeur de vie va plus
vite parce que c'est difficile d'aller
mais moi d'aller plus vite que di donna
vie ils sont vu son jeu des nazis et
plus expérimentés ont entre guillemets
parce qu'il a fait deux saisons initiés
il est même plus référencés au lycée
quand il était à la lumière dans
l'indiana il a vu dans plusieurs
contextes récemment et les champions du
monde le 19 avec avec team usa shedden
sharp lui c'est
un athlète qui a buzz et depuis un an
parce qu'il a il a vraiment explosé tout
le monde sur ce circuit et you l'été
dernier puis
quand on voit la tête que c'est on
comprend que c'est un film incroyable
parce qu'il a appris à shooter changelog
peut-être plus
cachée de la vie on connaît plus ses
faiblesses parce qu'on a plus énormément
joué mais je dois jada ellie plus rapide
plus tranchant loin du ballon qui
commence à développer un tir shedden
charles m plus avoir la balle pour tirer
pour couleurs notamment est très
verticale dans vers le cercle
défensivement dit donald vie très
agressif plan du ballon mais un peu
frêle pour défendre sur le porteur de
balle et je donne sharp a jamais
vraiment des projets
quand je les ai vus jouer donc ses
impôts les différences
celle de sharp je vous affiche son son
profil physique déjà il est plus grand
que jaden avila cm but de plus et il ya
une dizaine de centimètres de plus
d'envergure est très long
les plus longs et donc il a là ni peut
potentiellement
plus être peut-être un profil 2 3
défensifs
ivy bean et à est costaud il peut des
stands des joueurs un peu plus grande
dépense et blanc sur cette piste qui
pourrit pourra plus défendre avec 2,3
tandis que gianni pourra plus défendre
les hindous
offensivement leur rôle est plutôt
d'appoint de la balle en main ou de
faire des coeurs georges ballon va était
forcément sur qui peuvent défendre dans
nba à terme de plus de trois pour sharp
l'un d'eux pourrait générer
offensivement comment comment tu les
vois évoluer au l'un et l'autre autour
de kay qui donc joue beaucoup de pick
and roll a beaucoup le ballon a besoin
d'une menace verticale on l'a dit mais
aussi de joueurs qui sont là eux en cas
de edge enfin voilà joueurs qui savent
prendre des décisions rapidement et
demain et de maintenir grâce à leurs
capacités techniques la pression créée
par kuyt sur la défense
on a perdu à l'âne je crois il est en
rouge
emploie 7 sur le sur la taxe des
dépisteurs est ce que toi tu imagines
plus quelqu'un qui va chez pas monter la
balle ensuite la passer à quelqu'un qui
est capable de
de créer le décalage d'un côté et
ensuite le
transférer le ballon change et deux
côtés du terrain pour que kay deux
exploits de cette différence
comment tu vois les profils arrière
autour de caïds entre les profils québec
richard
descoings
ils veulent garder le ballon de quelques
lignes sommes donc ça c'est plutôt lui
qu elle ballon en premier qui commencent
à avancer les choses maintenant je dis
ça avec des pincettes parce qu'encore
une fois de la priorité c'est que là
qu'il ya un bac pro qui marche vraiment
un vrai un dieu qui marche et par lan
qui revient mais du coup
donc voilà si si c'est possible avec des
qualités premières du joueur qui vont
drafté que cet équilibre se trouvera
même si là on se dit c'est plutôt à
quelques d'hingham d'avoir la balle des
volonté d'organiser le truc si on a un
joueur qui permet à clips de faire autre
chose et que finalement ce
comité c'est que diego quelques lingam
et un autre joueur qui soit un back up
vraiment vraiment
personne qui va dans ce sens à une
différence donc encore une fois ça va
être la qualité première du joueur qui
est drafté qui va ajuster le reste moi
ce que je veux dire je pense pas qu'ils
ont prévenu que tu te définis en tête
une femme par action
valentin pour toi aussi c'est plus une
feuille blanche ont une histoire déjà à
moitié écrite
bien sûr après là effectivement il reste
encore les prochaines semaines je pense
vont être assez décisive pour dire quand
même faire une hiérarchie forcément
avant la draft pour revenir sur dia de
naïli aussi pour l'anecdote je reviens
un petit peu sur sa biographie il ya son
son père qu'elle avait prouvé son grand
père qui a joué pour les lion's
j'essayais d'en parler frère alan donc
ils ont quand même un petit un petit
truc lié liga avec détroit ce que les
fans de piste on aime beaucoup quand tu
ramènes du détroit à detroit mais pour
revenir à un petit peu plus sur le
basket je pense que à lévis est
aujourd'hui celui qui
est un peu plus facile forcément à
imaginer plus ou moins comme en asie et
qu'ils joueront parce que effectivement
ok il a besoin d'un bras droit sur le
pas-de-porte pour évidemment ne pas
avoir trop 3 faire non plus cette année
c'est pas un enfant c'est pas normal
chacun défend comme comme il le souhaite
mais c'est vrai que kelly les dés
étaient déjà doublé voire triplé en
défense parce que les équipes ont très
vite compris que bah c'était le seul à
faire la musique on va dire en attaque
et c'est un peu le souci de qui analyse
et c'est que qui analyse et un très bon
meneur pour mener typiquement c'est un
joueur intelligent qui connaît je pense
qu'ils gèrent très bien une attaque
qu'il ya par contre en terme de scoring
c'est un peu trop faible et c'est le
problème en fait un petit dianov bol
c'était compliqué donc il faut trouver
ce joueur qui arriva à la fois et des
caïds à la création qu'il ya un bon
créateur mais qui est capable quand même
de se montrer assez explosif au scoring
un peu partout sur le terrain et là
dessus je pense qu' il y ait un peu plus
polyvalent peut-être en attaque par
rapport à sharp et surtout c'est encore
une fois une valeur peut être un peu
plus sur du
tattoo territoire en dehors des parquets
de de sharp c'est forcément plus un
point d'interrogation
il ya deux questions il ya
des tas de dépasser avec l'invisible
ya deux questions il ya la question de
oxalis qui dit qu'il est deux le mieux
c'est
d oui parce que qu'ils ne jouent pas 48
min par match
par match et l'autre question c'est si
on part d'abord sur jay denney dit
comment ils s'insèrent offensivement
vraiment en coin dans le système voilà
en pick and roll est-ce que lui il va
pouvoir et aussi je posais l'écran est
ce que lui doit sortir d'un stack
d'heure à l'opposé pour prendre de la
vitesse comment tu vois comment tu
imagines une attaque avec jada n'a dit
quelqu'un chez donald je penserai à
qualité principale sur l'athlète que
nous y sommes c'est qu'en fait il va
être capable sur la création secondaires
donc ce n'est pas un prix implique and
roll et qui est un grand personnage vers
lui de part son premier bal et sa
vitesse d'attaqué de suite le mismatch
pour aller au cercle et en ceux qui lui
pourra vous mettre à leur prendre la
décision de refaire du drive-in kick ou
de ou de finir parce qu'en fait m
quelqu'un qui est virevoltant balle en
main qui est hyper tranchant ça peut
aider parce que qu'elle n'est pas le
plus tranchant balle en main en fait
avoir un deuxième profil de deuxième
créateur quelqu'un qui bouge très bien
loin du ballon peut jouer au football
qui peut
aussi potentiellement tirer alors le
catch and shoot c'est quelque chose qui
est en travail chez lipp mais il
travaille tellement il a tellement
toujours où travailler et progresser
d'année en année que je ne mets pas de
limite sur ses capacités à être un bon
joueur de catch and shoot sous des faux
ou simple que le futur en sortie
dribbles je pense surtout que ça me rate
beaucoup dynamisme sur la la création
secondaire des renversements il pourra
prendre des décisions attaquer le cercle
il pourra profiter des missions à tout
prix ce que l'on va peut-être mettre le
meilleur défenseur sur les extérieurs
sûr qu'elle va être commis dans un jour
un peu plus grand est mort happé double
trop petit pour le pouvoir le gérer donc
je vois que des plus positifs à m
ivy etc et écharpe sur dans même
charpente à connaître caïd pour pour lui
déjà lui enlever un peu de capacité de
lui enlever toute l'activité de création
lui offrir une menace or gold et
potentiellement développés un deuxième
créateurs je pense qu'en fait il ya tu
peux pas vraiment raté si tu cherches ce
genre de profil à amata côtés de kyle et
je pense que c'est ce genre de profil
acquis pour lui mettre une gui pas
d'accord avec toi il dit il tirait son
en cas de chinois qui apparemment
l'explosion c'est
max truths et unique
effectivement c'est plus compliqué à mes
distances balle en main pour qu'on a on
avait les deux je vous ai aimés les
stats on voit pas que c'est celle de
heidi mais celle de eli avec la
progression effectivement sur le tir à
trois points que ce soit en termes de
volumes ou en termes de pourcentage
entre l'année 1 et l'année deux
côtés de purdue donc le volume est pas
très haut
2,3 tirs à trois points par match c'est
pas s'il d'un joueur qui a une grande
confiance en sentir s'est pas tu t'en
prenait 5 par match on prenait 5 cette
année quatre de l'an dernier
2,3 à 25% à la papa
[Musique]
tu as raison c'est 2,3 marqués
par match
on avait de la deuxième question était
qui est le people le milieu seconde est
sur toi la population tu disais ivy
meilleur passeur
mike phillips pendant les entraînements
cette année avait dit que celle de sharp
avec beaucoup progressé nous avons
effectivement lycée il ya des touches en
est une où il y avait le ballon tout en
visitant les a ajoutés sur tout le monde
on est allé au cercle
jc il s'était pas trop envie de passer
je crois mike schmid dans ce qu'il dit
clairement parce que c'est pas quelqu'un
qui raconte des bêtises mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui après deux ans il y en
eut la balle tournant surtout l'an passé
papa de manière héliocentrique un jeu de
perdre je m'étais pas d'ailleurs pas
beaucoup pick and rolls pas un jeu
extrêmement transposable directement nba
mais on l'a vu prendre des décisions
balle en main un niveau supérieur à
charbon aujourd'hui je dirais que rêviez
meilleur à la création je pense pas que
ça s'est passé potentiellement pas le
cas dans cinq ans ni même dans trois ans
mais c'est le cas aujourd'hui
antoine on l'a dit on va nous raconter
l'histoire mais celle de sharp n'a pas
joué cette saison n 6
il aurait pu
il aurait pu jouer son conseil
je perds toujours son nom mais l'homme
derrière chaque dom sharp kiné et qui
n'est pas son père ou une fois mis son
beau-père qui m'aimait qu'il ya un
conseiller non plus souvent des ongles
aussi non c'est pas le ce n'est pas long
que je crois qu'il n'est pas de la
famille knicks quasiment sur la chaîne
a dit voilà il jouera pas
mais vous inquiétez pas big blue nations
can you qui tout va bien l'année
prochaine vous avez vos ex coureur il
sera lâché des sharks ont un problème
l'eau a coulé sous les ponts et pendant
que l'eau a coulé sous les ponts lui il
aller toquer aux portes toujours ce même
homme mystérieux des franchises nba hier
disant
monsieur mon poulain sheldon charte il
va à la draft et vous pouvez voir les
vidéos de l'année dernière cette année
joue pas mais vous pouvez voir les
vidéos de l'année n 1 est très fort à la
combined ça c'est un petit peu répété il
a pas il n'a pas énormément du sila fait
un trop des essais tout ce qu'il a fait
donc est ce que pour toi ça ça pose un
problème et est-ce que historiquement
tata le souvenir de joueur qu'on est à
qui ont un peu reculé à harasta cause de
ces manoeuvres agencière
ça dépend surtout qu'ils sont les
équipes qui draft dans les premiers
choix c'est pas forcément il ya des
profils comme ça qui se sont un petit
peu caché on peut dire je crois
d'ailleurs que joue cette carte c'est
dans l'idée vu comme un mystery men
comme
qu'on pense qu'il peut avoir un
potentiel génial parce que du coup c'est
pas forcément c'était génial ça crée un
peu
ça émoustille un petit peu comme ça donc
voilà il en joue beaucoup je pense que
le tchèque du combat c'était à manderen
peut s'installer dans le même sens donc
c'est est scénarisé et donc du coup
voilà c'est sûr on sait pas trop c'est
clair que les des promesses
il avait envie d'aller avoir 19 ans
avant la draft il avait eu son diplôme
du lycée avant que la saison mais
comment donc il pouvait être éligible
tôt c'était vraiment des c'était de la
parole dans le 20 mai encore une passe
c'est laura qu'il ya autour de ce jour
là c'est du narratif comme médicis et
voilà donc c'est la cc de la vente en
fait quoi pour l'instant tout ce qu'on a
c'est du commercial et ça peut marcher
ça peut marcher parce que déjà les
américains aiment bien les histoires
parce que le business avait écrit ça
leur va bien aussi et que voilà il garde
il ya quand même des éléments pour
évaluer son jeu et encore une fois de
toute façon n'importe quelle équipe qui
prend un jour aujourd'hui se dit quand
même quelques mois déjà intégré le
développer etc sauf les knicks ils sont
pas très bons en développement mais bon
tu vois que je passe un truc sur les
knicks excusez moi mais j'ai dix ans de
madison square garden à évacuer dans les
podcasts donc voila mais sinon
voila c
c'est vraiment ça et des idées il est
vraiment étiquetés comme ça il est vendu
comme ça en fin de
match et on a fait en même temps il peut
se le permettre parce qu'il ya ces
qualités qu'on a vu là il ya un vrai
échoue que tu disais alan quand on sent
qu'il ya quelque chose qui se passe à ce
niveau là on connaissait évidemment ses
qualités athlétiques mais ce n'est pas
forcément ce qui permet de juste sur la
différence vu que ce qu'il ya dans un
hamac du nord maintenant il faut dire
qu'on peut dire qu aux etats unis vu ce
qui se passe de
tout qui est en même temps viennent
beaucoup ici hein mais quand même et du
coup ouais je trouve que c'est un joueur
voilà qui
encore une fois on ne sait pas tout mais
ça ne va pas du tout à son encontre je
veux dire c'est une amie à côté un peu
le fait d'avoir du caractère
d'assumer ce genre de position et c'est
ça ça peut démontrer peut-être une force
mentale moi j'aime pas trop quand on dit
des trucs comme ça surtout quand c'est
encore une fois quelqu'un d'autre dans
son entourage qui orchestrent un peu
tout ça mais bon il va faire des
interviews quand même
c'est pas non plus comme sahin qui eux
pour jouer la carte du mystère il était
là je fais une interview avec le choix
numéro un et c'est tout quoi
quand même pas là donc on va voir on va
voir mais c'est le côté un peu suspense
on
sait bien que ça met du piquant tu l'as
dit une draft encore une fois même les
meilleurs des meilleurs des meilleurs
des meilleurs qui se retrouvent à cette
position de décisionnaire au rugby et
non pas lecture complète du futur et
c'est donc que y ait ce côté un petit
peu comme ça
sympa dans le sens du récit et c'est
toujours un petit peu intéressé par ça
peut-être en sortent d'ailleurs du coup
pourquoi moi ça me va
il a fait une interview il a donné une
interview
au média chan charogne un qui moi qui
moi m'a semblé très
écrites à l'avancé outre est monté je
sais pas mais c'était
il avait l'air de connaître les
questions qui lui arrive est parce que
c'était pas des questions il perd
basique genre tu voulais être champion
nba quand tu étais petit
donc ça m'a paru un petit peu
monté contrairement aux interviews en
live qui avait pendant le combat n'y
faisait mike schmidt qui était plus
spontané même si je pense que les
joueurs savaient aussi les clips on
connaissait les kills qu'on a les normes
montrer
ça c'est une question qui pour moi par
contre normalement en tant que
journaliste tu t'es pas censé donner
l'écho de la déontologie américaines là
dessus est la même que chez nous
si tu veux en pareil cas de toute façon
les deux sphères qui ont le cul de
connivence entre les journalistes et les
acteurs principaux c'est la politique et
le sport
donc il ya forcément des acteurs du coup
qui en trois ans a respecté la
déontologie date ou pire
était couru que j'ai bougé
en détail la jerry vandam rami je me
focalise juste après les finales parce
qu'il faut être sur les plaisirs ça mais
je garderai à ce moment là je suis même
pas ce que tu as dit mais ça
m'étonnerait pas on va dire par contre
ça qu'on est jeune et j'ai bien aimé là
j'ai lu ce qu'il avait fait avec
récemment la et jusqu'à demain on a vu
un petit week-end qui était pas tout à
fait à l'aise déjà c'est pas quelqu'un
qui a une personnalité arabe est mais en
plus effectivement il y avait un docu
délire des questions et je vais voir je
suis un peu testé et ses
machines on est très fan de ses
interviews pourrait
évaluer généralement là
la psychologie du joueur la manière dont
ils parlent se comporte comme ans il
c'est le tien etc c'est des choses qui
sont intéressants on n'est pas les
morphologies selon plus
tirer des leçons là-dessus pions finir
sur sharp raivis valentin chez toi chez
la femme bay chai qui ressort des médias
pickton c'est plus ivy parce que tout ce
que tu disais avant historique avec
détroit moins de risques et puis
potentiel quand même oui c'est
exactement ça c'est la d3 on est dans
une optique de vouloir comme le disait
en préambule le profil qui a le meilleur
équilibre en soi si on prend en compte
toutes les cases et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ivy a le meilleur profil
on va dire dans le sens où il ya quand
même moins de points d'interrogation que
que sharp ou du moins en moins de gros
points d'interrogation par rapport à
charge qui évidemment a déjà tout d'une
storytelling particulière autour de lui
donc forcément
on va dire que le consensus dans le
michigan
tire plus vers very easy
jet de nay didon vas-y à la
voie juste pour ajouter
celle de sharp je compte il aurait tout
perdu a joué à cannes turkistani après
il va se faire avoir dans le top 100
donc les gens disent oui pourquoi il n'a
pas joué il avait rien à gagner il va se
faire drafté dans le top 5 ou dans le
top a les dalton s'ils jouent à kentucky
qu'est ce qui fait peut se blesser il
peut ne pas aimer bon c'est possible ne
pas être bon dans une équipe qui était
pas incroyable cette année c'était
batala au début de marche mais ce par
simple it hurts quand même qu'ils
étaient un peu blessé donc je pense que
il avait rien à gagner donc les gens
disent ouais c'est pas bien qu'il n'ait
pas joué oui mais ils n'avaient pas
grand chose à gagner la fois il va
commencer par barton loterie alors que
pour mais inquiets pour une fois à quel
point on extrapole ça je sais plus j'ai
lu ça mais dans ce cas est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'ils sous tendent et recel
ou victor wanyama doivent s'asseoir
l'année et attend de la rue raphaël bar
local disent ah oui c'est vrai au mitan
one man's bones ne peut ne pas jouer un
match l'an prochain j'aurai quand même
on aura de mon bord donc c'est super
complet c'est super problématique hull
sur l'évaluation des propos
aussi que les mecs réfléchissent qu'il
n'y a pas que pour la draft quoi
s'insurge début de carrière
exceptionnelle combien ssl équilibre à
trouver du coup toujours
absolument puisque une année sans jouer
c'est pas une année
juste de sympathiques surtout à l'âge
lequel
et qui glycines
valentin et tout le monde a mentionné je
prenais à led sont
protiva pie xii
s'il se fait pas les croisés puis le
pied ces numéros en avoir mais
c'était mon joueur préféré il ya deux
ans quoi tous est gras de cette cuvée
2022 il se fait quand on l'avait vu
jouer 2 pour la première fois qu'à 16
ans en 2019 avec team c'était incroyable
c'était un poste 3 passes et dribbles et
shooter avec un physique de buffle déjà
et ensuite il ya eu malheureusement les
croisés et il ya eu le pied
qu'il faut qu'ils allaient éloigner des
terrains pendant quasiment dix sept mois
donc pas de saison junior high school
une saison senior high school
miné par les blessures et par locaux
vides
tellement qu'en fait au début d'année
quand je regardais dans mon top 10 c'est
vrai que c'était vraiment un vrai pari
parce que il ne jouait pas beaucoup
début donné à l'udc duke
il joue et était resté au logo txeroki
les jeunes freshman qui tire un peu la
couverture est ensuite criigen a dû
d'abord se remettre physiquement
retrouver un rythme pour ensuite sur la
deuxième partie de saison être un des
meilleurs shooteurs du pays un des
meilleurs freshman twitter qu'on a pu
voir surtout 1 kg une joute un physique
de buffle même si je ne trouve plus
lourd qu'avant malheureusement je trouve
qu'il a perdu cette explosivité qui
faisait lui se profile incroyable aux
ailes
mais voilà un joueur qui allait
peut-être le potentiel d'être une star
vraiment un hellip moderne n'est que
maintenant que tout faire un genre qui
va peut-être se spécialiser dans la
défense les tirs à trois points avec
toujours des flashs à autre chose mais
qui reste très jeune qui reste comme l'a
dit antoine un fils de coach il a passé
un peu tout le vide et sa rééducation
attend pas la nôtre l'organe avec les
raptors qui était décalée à tampa bay
donc il connaît déjà l'environnement
professionnel
et voilà donc monsieur cissé le dossier
médical comment va son genou comment va
son pied il est plus des soucis un peu
de poids je trouvais aussi sur par
moments mais
un joueur
pendant ces incroyables et déjà un patin
potentiel un plancher de shooter déjà
très forte chute pas quasiment 46% à 3
points on a 18 ans à dieu comme ça
valentin est ce qui manque encore du
shoot en d3
ah bah il manque même beaucoup de shoots
et 3 jamais tenir donc c'est pour ça que
j'en parlais tout à l'heure je pense je
ne vois pas non plus à moins d'une
compagnie d'un mois de juin incroyable
je ne vois pas troy le prend dans cinq
ici on n'a que le pic 5 ça m'étonnerait
quand même beaucoup par contre
effectivement si le trade de jarrat
migrants de ce fait qu'on arrive à avoir
un pixel tout même ne serait-ce qu'un
autre pique un peu plus bas et qu'elle
est sa cote reste plus ou moins stable
il pourrait vraiment la ville le tenter
parce que finalement ça reste un pari
c'est on va dire que c'est quand même
assez
on va dire un petit risque mais le on va
dire que ça peut être qu'il ya une très
grosse récompense si le développement se
passe bien comme la diane lane voilà
c'est quand même il a quand même un père
dans le milieu un père qui connaît trois
hivers parce que parce que il était
avocat ici quand troy weaver et non la
direction donc il connaît le papa il
connaît même très bien le papa donc à
tout moment quand il voulait dit il peut
aller se boire une bière avec avec le
papa pour en parler donc effectivement
je pense que il n'est pas indifférent et
pour rebondir ce que disait antoine par
rapport ce côté un peu 27 fou fou de
trois hivers
le voir des trois prendre griffin
avec un pic c'est un coup un pic sept ça
serait surprenant mais connaissant le 3
8 heures c'est possible vraiment c'est
possible vraiment ils aiment bien faire
ce genre de choses et pour reprendre ce
que disait diem seaworld de dianétique
détroit il disait que finalement détroit
parce que évidemment ait eu la déception
d'avoir le pic 5 passes compte fermer
les portes sur un des trois monstres
devant mais comme il le disait
finalement c'est ça reste un pic 5 et
c'est bien plus important d'avoir le pic
à la haine à l'air que le pic atteint le
pic s'installer ou 1 puis 3 ou 2 cette
année enfin c'est ce qu'ils ont dit a
partiellement du piston tijd bon bah les
pistes au nom caïds et on va avoir payé
pendant cinq ans donc c'est un 4 3 6
détroit il faut juste bien drafté quoi
et bien développé et là dessus il faut
faire confiance aux à notre board qui
quand même scouts plutôt bien et si ça
arrive à bien développer le pixar qui on
arrive en plus à avoir un pixel et 8,9
enfin le blocry c'est un coup double
intéressant nous c'est ce qu'on a dit
l'immédiatement d'ailleurs
évidemment qu'il valait mieux avoir le
pic en l'année dernière que même le big
1 cette année
car
même noblet partir enfin cette année
donc
assez longs mois selon toi aussi je
pense donc oui c'est de toutes les
grappes ne se valent pas avoir le vin
dans une année ça vaut pas avant l'heure
à toute objection charest espère là
dessus c'est juste que je mets quand
même l'accent sur le fait que c'est
quand même pas mal des pressions de la
loire en pic saint quentin a vendangé
plus ou moins en tout cas ça ne coûte
pas mais ça ne marche pas trop ton
pixels de l'année d'avant quoi il ya
deux ans les deux ans avec un baril qui
vient d'arriver
oui oui on est d'accord mais du coup
moins faut pas trop qu'il se pende quand
même conçu un jeu sorti en deux avec un
futur titulaire nba solidaire après a
précisé que de votre guilde de sport
déjà en lutte masculine et sur avis
c'est un jeu souvent quand on voit des
gens 2d 3d parle de tous les sports
qu'il ya des trois
c'est une ville qui aime son basket et
qui a envie que le basket en reviennent
au premier plan
je pense qu'il ya quand même un petit
peu de pression
peut-être que le fusible s'éclaircir mai
mais quand même je
dis pas qu'il est menacé où il va mais
on n'est pas trop ce ponte fallait bien
que ça marche pas là quand même
alors qu'il ya le sait si elle a une
voix très juste et qu'effectivement
sendra tu as un joueur de toute façon le
monde à savoir moi je vous dis juste
rapidement l'étudiante one le pic de
keegan est évidemment encore
une petite défection pour un pic sept
mais pour moi qu'il faut pas l'enterrer
non plus parce qu'il a quand même fait
une saison quasi-blanche odeurs outils
le talent et l'intelligence est quand
même là il s'entend bien avec qui il
s'entend mais les easy donc c'est pour
ça que je pour le moment je ne m'imagine
par rapport à ce que tu disais je pense
que kenzy est quand même beaucoup plus
en danger que trois mineurs malgré le
fait que qu'ils y jouissent jouit quand
même 2 du fait d'avoir la confiance de
ses de ses joueurs il est quand même
aimé dans le vestiaire mettez-y faut pas
l'oublier on en a parlé dans d'autres de
transport notamment au psg récemment le
coach il n'a pas été choisi par 3,8 à
tout moment ça peut péter et c'est quand
même la première grosse des trois
mineurs c'est de se débarrasser du coach
qui étaient là avant son arrivée quand
même parce que finalement il a toujours
pas choisi son coach encore un autre
éleveur donc il faut pas l'oublier que
trois hivers aussi il était avant il
était dans la fac de gilles et à
syracuse il me semble à l'époque des
mélos
donc c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a
gardé de très bons contacts avec
certains quotas laitiers des volets donc
à tout moment il peut être amené un
jeune d'une fac ou un truc comme ça
parce qu'il est quand même très attaché
au basket universitaire donc à tout
moment qui existe à peu sauté et je
pense que c'est le premier qui sautera
parce qu'une reconstruction c'est bien
beau il n'y a pas de pression on était
contents on va dire de perdre en
envoyant du beau jeu mais si l'année
prochaine on a encore que 20 ou 22 ou 23
victoires avec après la troisième année
de reconstruction va peut-être falloir
quand même commencer à réfléchir surtout
qu'on a quand même encore une fois une
enveloppe de 40 millions cet été donc si
en plus on parvient à battre phoenix
dans la course pour des andes rayton tu
commences tu sais que tu commences à
avoir du talent faux pas ne faut pas
être en dessous des 30 victoires et
prochaine parce que tu dis ça peut
sauter chance
on va revenir sur les greens mais je
profite du fait que vous soyez encore
très nombreux pour vous dire de 6,2 vous
abonner si vous ne l'êtes pas encore que
ce soit sur youtube ou sur vos plates
formes d'écouté puisque depuis nos
podcasts et ses lives ensuite sont
disponibles partout spotify deezer
stitcher appel podcast c'est partout et
ça sort donc si vous abonnez vous à la
petite notice et vous pouvez vous mettre
ça dans votre sport ans au moins ou pour
vous endormir avec la douce voix d'alan
guillot qui va nous parler des gee
griffin avec une question précise prot
précise même mais intéressante de
pierres parce que tout le monde parle de
la gestion
de hadji griffin qui pourrait expliquer
j'ai pas de vidéo montrée mais en gros
il a les pieds beaucoup plus que largeur
est folle quand vous êtes à l'école de
basket on vous dit la bonne gestuelle
vous avez à peu près les pieds largeur
et paul alignement genou
orteils voilà l'huile est pyramidal
exactement totalement pire la médaille
sur le catch and shoot et les cas c'est
un relais avec pépin physique
il n'était pas comme ça sur le vol du
corps à 16 ans d'ailleurs souvent à 16
ans 15 16 ans des fois les beaucoup
poussent la voile par manque de
puissance lui il était déjà capable
d'avoir un tir qui ressemblait vraiment
à vrai dire à son âge c'est vrai que là
son tir est pyramidale en fait on dirait
la tour eiffel en titre vraiment c'est
hyper hyper impressionnant après
l'accident
ça sera bien pour le match à paris d'où
exactement si jamais les critiques mais
dont kiel et après ça a toujours été un
très bon tireur
c'est un sur les portages lancers-francs
aussi même si ce test est pas un droit
parce qu'elle n'est pas beaucoup en fait
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que ce talent
il a été cantonné à un rôle de potiche
shooter en fait il faisait ça au levant
le giro avait la balle le monde chiron
craie et trevor qu'il y avait aussi bien
me roach et en fait on n'a quasiment pas
vu et jerry finn crest voland pourvoir
et décline créé moment il faut retourner
au lycée à new york ou parce qu'il en a
une a fait son lycée par là bas ou avec
timur essais en plus 16 il ya
trois ans loin dans quasiment donc
c'était un rôle différent pour lui avant
lui qui ressemblera sûrement plus à ce
qu'il en nba un rôle qui ressemble à
skis là aussi les philosophes pistols
parce que kate est le créateur de
l'équipe mais en tout cas il ya un vrai
toucher
et je pense pas que cette mécanique
l'empêchent en catch and shoot cette
mécanique par contre peut l'empêcher à
être plus fluide sur dudus la sortie
dream du poulpe parce que il est
peut-être moins fluide des mois tonique
sur le mode du corps
jetés enchaîne avec une autre question
du chat le neuf en lui même qui nourrit
création de tir
la création de chaires dj
wiwi dj ou est ce qu'il est capable de
se créer
moi j'ai déjà vu secret sentir je penche
déjà musclé sentir dans dans plusieurs
contextes cette année on l'a vu par
flash on va me secret sentir quand il
était vraiment en confiance il était
capable avec un crossover ensuite un
système back de la droite vers la gauche
de le faire après c'était plus les
griffin pluie des badges et griffin
tranchant capables de créer de l'espace
sur sur le dream pourra pour s'élever
ensuite donc en fait
j'aurais dit oui il ya un an là je
dirais un peu moins mais je dirais qu'il
a par contre progressé en catch and
shoot voit la
progression oui bah 45% sur site en
presque sept tentatives à 18 ans et
c'est vraiment impressionnant ouais
c'est un des joueurs les plus jeunes de
la draft fait bien de souligner aussi
par exemple un an de moins complet que
jedi vie dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
tu as vu des 18 mois deux mois coach est
quand même
ouais
on va parler enfin valentin est revenu
c'est parfait on va parler de la
possibilité de tri idée puisque c'est
quelque chose qui est revenu
régulièrement
depuis le début de ce live valentin
explique moi tout ça vient c'est petit
stress de l'idée de trédias s'est fondée
ou quoi jeremy grande contre nous c'est
juste un fantasme et après on verra à
quel point ça vaut un clic de draft etc
puisque l'on parle germyn grande contre
1 pixel est ce que ça les vaut ça sera
la deuxième question mais d'abord ça
vient d'où
bah déjà ça vient je pense dans ce
dossier on s'est un peu partagé mais
c'est une rumeur qui revient quand même
beaucoup s'y était déjà le cas avant
même la fin de la saison parce que il y
avait l'histoire du pile protéger avec
portland dans le trail de mc collum donc
portland aurait pu avoir aussi le pic
des peines donc avoir deux pics
genre je crois que c'était une
protection de loterie ont du coup les
pays qui sont quand même à la fin de la
loterie mais si l'épée dickens avait été
40 16 c'est le pic aurait été
important donc déjà là on en parlait
d'une possibilités de trades pour
peut-être récupérer le 16 donc déjà
cette rumeur détroit portland et roy
portland autour de dire un migrantes on
en parle quand même déjà avant même la
loterie et maintenant avec la loterie
avec son regroupe pourront croiser un
peu les rumeurs comme quoi portland
n'est toujours pas enclin
malheureusement pour les fans de
portland à reconstruire totalement ils
veulent encore entouré entouré d'un
milliards dé ses terrasses et un flou un
petit peu perpétuel et
apparemment le profil de durham y
plairait énormément
à portland énormément à billups donc
c'est pour ça maintenant à mon humble
avis il faut savoir être objectif malgré
tout le respect que j'ai pour lui et tu
sais que j'adorais migrants surtout
l'année dernière il a fait une très
belle saison pour moi ça ne vaut jamais
un pic sept maintenant
qu'est-ce que portland peu drafté ce que
devra s que portland que réellement
draft et là je voudrais je m'adresse
plus tôt à la ddt avec un pic cette
caisse qui peut vraiment avoir vu un
joueur à ce point-là utile dans le par
rapport à leurs objectifs ce que tu
parlais d'une rave quand même assez
ouverte
si vraiment encore une fois on parlait
de l'importance de la stratégie de la
philosophie d'un dirigeant il peut avoir
des dirigeants qui sont assez chaud sur
cette grave parce qu'ils ont travaillé
qui juge qu' il ya des joueurs utiles
pour leur organisation peut-être que
portland c'est l'extrême opposé et dans
ce cas là autant avoir un pic sept et
d'échangé d'avoir ingéré migrantes voilà
importante qui apportent un plus et en
plus ils ont en plus d'une somme de
l'argent ils sont également sur les
rangs drayton portland donc s'ils
arrivent à compléter tu peux quand même
avoir une belle équipe autour de l'île
heard donc voilà c'est à voir ceux déjà
tout dépendra de ce que je fais pourtant
autour de détroit mais effectivement je
suis je pense que comme chaque année 3
wheeler va essayer d'avoir un optique
mon premier 2 draft
maintenant à voir
comment ça fonctionne comment
s'articulent et surtout qui choisit quoi
dans le top 10 parce que par exemple on
sait jamais mais si détroit par miracle
se retrouve avec un des trois monstres
devant ça veut dire que peut-être
sacramento trop rapide erreur ou une
surprise du moins et si jay bybee peut
être encore disponibles en 6 ça
peut-être sharp ans est peut-être que là
ça peut très vite explosé à détroit pour
avoir faire un coup double à ses
immenses mais oui jérémie grant est sur
le départ et
trouvera toujours dit qu'en cas de
départ de grant c'est qu'ils cherchent
en priorité c'est un premier tour de
draft donc saffré sens mais par rapport
à une autre rumeur aussi on parlait
d'une rumeur du pic 5 avec grant pour
trade hub dans le top 3 ça moi j'y crois
pas parce que ça voudrait dire que tu
sacrifies quand même une carte qui est
une valeur marchande pas négligeable
tout ça pour entre guillemets t'assurer
bonne terreau ou smith bon je suis pas
certain qu'on irait jusqu'à là pour
grimper que d'une place ou deux
latuquois
alan quelles valeurs on a sûrement peaks
est dans cette draft selon toi
évidemment au parole d'oracle
pas incroyable
c'est une grande tasse qui plus est des
griffin pour moi en vraiment walker
ensuite si on regarde bah en fait y'a
juste à regarder laitière en fait les
groupes de joueurs que j'ai après j'ai
un groupe de joueurs qui va de 6 à 18
ans que
ça veut dire que c'est il ya plusieurs
possibilités mais c'est à dire qu'il ya
pas pour moi ces joueurs vraiment et
c'est normal en réalité on est en fait
on est à la mine au milieu de la loterie
c'est difficile à ses 7 passes hâte de
te retrouver alors ya toujours les
contre exemples bien sûr et heureusement
mais c'est difficile pour moi de trouver
un joueur qui peut à la fois avoir un
fort potentiel est à la fois aider tout
de suite franchise parce que je pense
que porte on veut être et des incas
d'amman et d'art dont une équipe donc
t'es pas là non plus pour jouer à la
loterie deux trois ans de suite m deux
ans de suite mais en même temps termes
de potentiel il s'agit toujours de bien
draft au potentiel important ils ont
pris les enfourner symons des menaces
tyrannie talent et tout ça au premier
tour donc je me dis que
je sais pas mais en fait tu trouveras
pas un joueur qui je pense demain
peut-être plus que jérémy quand ça il
faut être aussi réaliste là dessus
voici eux l'historique des pics est sûre
les dernière draft nous avons kobe
wendell carter laurie markkanen jamal
murray n'a duel mounier d'ulysse randle
ben mc le mort harrison barnes bismack
biyombo greg monroe stephen curry eric
gordon corey brewer prendre 10 feuilles
charlie villanueva lual deng kirk
hinrich nennig lario et 10 griffin est
celui qui est caché ses prix ce micro et
remy
l'immense chris mihm tout ça pour dire
que il ya quelques ratés il ya pas mal
de joueurs qu'on fait une bonne carrière
de titulaire nba et il ya évidemment une
ou deux stars qui se cache dans le monde
c'est fait
à moins de mesures
outre les fans des knickers bookers
direct depuis 32 ans m en réalité
antoine est ce que gerra migrantes qui
est un titulaire aujourd'hui n'diaye
qui à qui il reste deux ans de contrat
une année avant million une année à 21
est ce que ça vaut toujours et où il
reste une année de contrat cette
dernière a l'air il avait signé trois
ans il a fait de opi stone donc c'est la
dernière
2022 oui en 2022 n'importe quoi il reste
un an de contrat mais
je crois que d'ailleurs dans le trade
avec portland il ya d'options que du
coup le piston ce beauf le contrat
d'eric besson qui est aussi pas loin de
20 millions
ouais il avait figuré
détroit va être obligé de pays des gens
cet été pour être en dessous du 4
minimes voilà et dans sa range cd racing
ça arrange tout le monde c'est cette
notion à 2 par contre se débarrasse du
contrat de blade sur deux les pistols
peuvent le bouffer parce qu'ils ont la
place pourrait que bledsoe free agent
aussi en 2023 cpt c'était un des clés
aussi de te traite là c'est ça c'est
intéressant
donc g8 une parler de germiny
valoir
oui vas-y non je repose la question pour
ce qui arriverait mais est ce qu'il vaut
le coup d'être aidés pour un choix 7 qui
on l'a vu parfois elle vient parfois pas
bien je dirais que la moyenne c'est un
titulaire quatrième et cinquième en six
mois
bah dis donc c'est pour le long terme
quand les disques de façon ils vont pas
le garder après 2023 donc c'est plutôt
pour avoir quelqu'un avec qui tu côtier
de construire que tu peux même développé
c'est intéressant la draft c'est pas
juste prendre un joueur qu'on va avoir
maintenant passé c'est aussi un aspect
quelque chose il ya un potentiel il ya
on a dû un département pays en
développement et en plus de notre
département scouting on veut voilà
prendre un joueur il façonner c'est
quand même une des choses les plus
importantes derrière et donc du coup
pourquoi pas lui dire mais quand c'est
un très bon joueur québécois 22.6 comme
ça qui appartient dans le moins de
choses mais qui clairement ne fait pas
vraiment partie du projet pistols donc
le plus de valeur que tu prends tu y as
dernière
déclenche pas je vois que de toute façon
même avec lui c'est la deuxième pire
équipe à l'aise pour les ai quasiment la
pire équipe donc
[Musique]
donc donc pourquoi pourquoi le garder
pourquoi pas tenter des choses il faut
qu' il ya un petit peu du du remue
ménage et du revenu médian à detroit
donc
pour moi c'est feu quoi
mais il faut que en fassiez une option
qui soit valable pour ces il ya aussi
des valeurs aussi d'ailleurs ou tout
simplement un contrat qui expire à
beaucoup d'équipés qui vont prendre qui
expose même année donc c'est pas prendre
de ce trade là mais je crois que
d'ailleurs c'est à peu près ce qui
semble plus ou moins possible maintenant
tu me convient je l'entends pas qu'il
dote y pensait beaucoup à qui profite
beaucoup plus souvent maîtres une
oreille aux murs des rumeurs
sur des 3
il me semble que c'est ce qu'il semblait
un peu valables
oui bien sûr on a on a quand même
après jérémy grogne pour donner un ordre
d'idée à aux personnages ils écoutent la
valeur marchande l'a peut-être la plus
intéressante c'est kelly olynyk donc on
arrive à un moment où
kelly olynyk ça a quand même un petit
moindre mesure que jérémy grande parce
que voilà dans un migrant qui l'a été on
va dire il pleut il peut se
peut se réjouir d'avoir été dans la
discussion ne dans une semi discussions
d'eurostar l'année dernière quand il
avait fait la saison complète qui est
déjà très bien par rapport aux rôles
players qu'il était avant qu'une unique
ce qui a une valeur un peu marchande un
peu plus faible donc effectivement à 2,3
il n'ya que j'ai un micro sous presse il
a échangé et mine de rien c'est un trait
de ne pas rater parce que on n'a pas
souvent des valeurs marchandes
intéressante sur le marché bon c'était
le bord deux précédents mais on a pu
voir ce qui s'était passé avec deux
hymnes qui finalement a été échangé
contre
brandon knight et john henson parce
qu'on a attendu trop longtemps et bon
c'était le manager précédent mais mais
voilà ça te donne un ordre d'idée c'est
pas bon non plus de trop attendre et là
je pense que si c'est pas cet été elle
voudra dire que ça sera février prochain
et là ce sera beaucoup trop tard parce
qu'il restera que deux des trois mois à
son contrat c'est vrai cet été ou alors
il ira au bout de son contrat et on va
pas être mécontent mais ça très dommage
et céline dans le chat qui aux notes à
juste titre que cet été théoriquement
cette valeur sera plus forte cette
saison incroyable l'année prochaine mais
que d'abord de l'afrique deadline au
mois de février
on se dirige vers la fin vous mais juste
une question rapide pour valentin
quel profil au second tour disait est ce
qu'on est ce qu'on utilise ce choix de
draft si oui est ce qu'on va chercher
bout de sa rue grunner plus un meneur
bac + 5 et andy chez les trois options
bon moi je pense plutôt way un flux edi
poste 3-4 ça serait intéressant ou alors
à l'intérieur en fait tout dépendra de
l'avancée des négociations officielles
entre leighton et les pistols mais je
pense qu'un poste 4 c'est intéressant
surtout si grand part parce que
finalement il restera plus beaucoup de
monde sur le poste 4 donc ouais un droit
quatre flux edi 3,4 parce que encore une
fois je pense qu'il manque beaucoup trop
de te suit le shoot yvan fait office
tonnes donc si on peut choper un
artilleur prêts à la retirer en libye je
pense que ce serait une très bonne chose
autour de kate mais moto2 qui décidera
des citoyens ils restent sur le banc
notamment pour la seconde unité rajouter
du shooting a eu un peu jeune je pense
que ça ferait pas de mal
alan on voit des noms
chat charabia jay clara vient en 46 il
sera plus là parce qu'il commence à voir
une hype incroyable
ouais zhang yujun lee le premier corps
et la draft est possible très possible
moi je vois bien plus anciennement max
christine fil des ans
ces jeunes et ça shoote donc on a les
deux on a le potentiel plus simple après
moi je
je devrai bien prendre un ris mon run r
je pense grosse menace de log un
intérieur à développer type daniel
hugues laforte michelle robinson ce
genre de joueur la haye les apps ghani
khan chose à christian kologo
là qu'ils doutent a plein d alter y en a
énormément transcendant toutes les
drafts ou alors potentiellement
peut-être ses tâches et un joueur en
europe chez que ça arrive
les scouts des pistes sont toujours dans
les tournois en europe on les voit tout
le temps avec leur coeur leur avis des
pistols donc avoir
très bien ça sera le mot de la fin soc
évidemment antoine va longtemps quelque
chose à ajouter sur cette grave des
pistols un mot de conclusion 12 ou juste
leur souhaite bonne chance antoine
non je suis ravi que l'année parler de
l'intérieur a développé tout ça c'est
pas mal pour des trois jeux simples et
valentin aussi
sur moi un peu plus fans pensent à tout
de suite
voir un petit peu plus sur le
développement
donc puisque ça prend du temps qui parie
beaucoup
tranquille c'est bien d'aller chercher
des joueurs loin pendant le deuxième
tour pour ça c'est plus un projet mais
non tout ce que j'ai à dire si c'était
très sympa tu parles avec où j'avais ce
petit jeu je suis très transparents là
dessus j'ai pas énormément suivi les
pistons 101 de cette année je pense que
ça se comprend aussi j'espère mais mais
du coup c'est très intéressant elle
paraît qu'on a essayé généralement
juste un an et beaucoup de chemin tête
reprenant intéressante donc merci et de
l'invitation et bravo pour le travail
que vous faites
merci à toi pour les compliments et
d'être venu surtout peut-être disponible
à l'entente un mot de la fin
bah écoute et j'espère ne pas vous
revoir à la baisse
mais
moi je pense aux antilles dredd contents
de nous revoir l'année prochaine si tu
n'envoies l'année prochaine si tu alpiq
synchro chez moi apparemment oui
effectivement j'ai quelques
connaissances qui suivra une signal
magna s'était valan connais un peu du
conte français de duke et effectivement
il a presque envie qu'on soit encore nul
parce qu'il est fan des systèmes aussi
pour pouvoir avoir un bon pique l'année
prochaine mais ça a donné un mois ça
fait dix ans que je suis depuis dix ans
chez des pistols c'est vrai j'en ai un
petit peu marre depuis 2010 deux projets
sur la draft chaque année mais mais
voilà on te casse toujours un plaisir de
parler avec vous les gars de suivre de
tafer et j'étais ravi de enfin par les
douanes parce que en tant qu en deux
c'est un de l'équipe je veux lisez ces
ses articles au bureau donc donc voilà
toujours un plaisir de vous lire tout ça
tous les trois et puis et puis voilà
merci beaucoup alan on se retrouve
bientôt les prochaines les prochains
live pour ceux qui mouillent ce livre
sont le 30 mai on va parler du first ex
qu'on parlera d'orlando donc des débats
philosophiques
je vous l'annonçais direct et le
lendemain on va bien rigoler puisque on
parlera de sacramento
vote et 31
on va effectivement et le 7 juin les
blenders et il nous reste en live à
programmer on va faire un peu la fin de
la loppsi voilà qu'à chaque fois qu'un
membre des médias monde des fans est un
membre envergure merci à tous pour votre
participation encore encore une fois
vous avez été présent et c'est génial on
s'attendait pas à voir autant de
personnes qui regardent vraiment mettre
merci à vous et à bientôt suivez lost
its puisque en attendant 30 il va y
avoir du contenu soit sur les prospects
français que toi sur le prospect
donc voilà continue à suivre nos
contenus allez voir le site de
dailymotion lisez l'équipe pour les
papiers d'antoine sur la conférence est
et nous plutôt le sida j'ai dû courir le
match contre arras ouest hier soir par
avion du matin et ce sans chat sur mon
match mais là on va se calmer un petit
s'organiser pour normalement je suis
plutôt
loïc pialat à l'ouest
l'excellent de pialat et la rédaction
une équipe qui comme valentin c'est du
coup bosse énormément sur la couverture
d un effort collectif c ou une personne
bien sûr higuain
et
bah écoute et j'affiche mon supporter
lis tu as
aidé moi là puisque j'y vais petit prono
pour le match sont à
moi j'ai moi j'ai dit que boston allait
exploser miami donc il faut absolument
qu'ils gagnent ce soir pour que j'ai
raison dans mon pronostic d'accord
moi je bosse en os x 7 x mer
noire d'où
est-ce que ce soir jack geipan de savoir
qui enfle et encore oui
mais non pas ils vont pas du bien
maintenant ils meurent en 91 matches
battant d'échauffement thierry sud le 10
mai
à la conférence de presse
ni ali un peu la seule équipe que je
n'arrive pas trop à cerner
ces playoffs quoi elle qui me
surprennent et sans cesse
alors
mes amis je pense que ça va ça peut
faire le taf mais je pense que ça va
être
un match
un match 5 toujours important mais je
vois bien miami au nez
on se chambre laura sur la bge aussi
pour
bon bon match antoine bon regarder dans
le chat vous fait des bisous vous
embrasse ciao ciao